good evening my name is Kayla McGee and
I am a junior studying politics and
journalism and it is my utmost pleasure
to introduce our speaker this evening
Anthony beaver who is a military
historian and a visiting professor at
the University of Kent and at Birkbeck
College University of London he served
in the British Army as a regular officer
in the 11th hussars a formerly Snow's
lecturer at Cambridge University and
chairman of the Society of authors he's
a fellow of the Royal Society of
literature and of the Royal Historical
Society he is a recipient of the
Pritzker Literature Award for lifetime
achievement in military writing and the
historical associations Norton Medlicott
medal for services to history in 2016 he
was made commander of the Order of the
crown in Belgium and he was knighted
earlier this year he's the author of
numerous books about World War two
including Stalingrad the fateful siege
1942 to 1943 please join me in welcoming
Sir Anton Weaver
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
the poets Fyodor Jovanovic to chef
famously said once that Russia cannot be
understood with the mind alone certainly
Putin's Russia today cannot be
understood without a knowledge of the
Second World War or the Great Patriotic
War as stalin called it according to a
Levada poll in June of this year 63
percent of Russians think that the USSR
could have been victorious in the Second
World War without any help from allies
that figure that figure has held fairly
steady for roughly the last 17 years
interestingly when Putin came to power
what is interesting is that the
percentage of Russians who think that
Stalin was most to blame for the very
high Soviet casualties in the war has
fallen from 37% in 1997 to 12% now the
rehabilitation of Stalin has indeed been
gathering speed today it's very hard to
appreciate the historical forces which
killed some 60 to 70 million people when
we dwell on the enormity of the Second
World War and its victims we try and
fail to absorb the reality of all of
their statistics of national and ethnic
tragedy the poles lost almost 6 million
people almost 1/5 of their population
estimates of total Soviet losses now
range from 24 to 26 million dead Stalin
knew in 1945 that they exceeded 20
million but he tried to conceal this as
David Reynolds the professor of
international relations at Cambridge
University pointed out he settled for
7.5 million as a figure that sounded
suitably heroic but not criminally
homicidal so less than a third of the
true figure according to the widely
respected calculations of the Bundeswehr
smilla target reserves for shrooms and
best to say that when you haven't had
too much wine the Red Army affected 4
million and 66 thousand fatal
casualties on the velm out of which
363,000 were prisoner of war deaths this
represents 76 percent or just over
three-quarters of the total Vermont
death toll of five million three hundred
eighteen thousand it is largely on this
basis that the USSR and now the Russian
Federation claimed that the Red Army
which break the back of the ver mark and
not the British or the Americans but of
course Putin like Stalin refuses to
acknowledge their contribution to save
its survival and ultimately allied
victory the total warfare on the Eastern
Front between 1941 and 1945 was quite
clearly the culmination of the
ideological process which accelerated
during the 1930s mass militarization
combined with mass indoctrination both
Hitler and Stalin utterly dehumanized
their enemies through propaganda and
their complete control of the media in
June 1941 the mark preparations for the
massive assault on the Soviet Union with
three million men prompted hopes of
rapid victory forests of birch and fur
along the nazi-soviet frontier concealed
vehicle parked 28th headquarters and
signals regiments as well as all the
fighting units officers German officers
briefed their men reassuring them that
he would only take three or four weeks
to crush the Red Army the unnatural
alliance of the molotov-ribbentrop pact
was over early tomorrow morning wrote a
soldier in a mansion division were off
thanks be to God against our mortal
enemy Bolshevism for me a real stone has
fallen from my heart
finally this uncertainty is over and one
knows where one is I am very optimistic
and I believe that if we can take all
the land and raw materials up to the
Urals then Europe will be able to feed
itself and it would not matter how long
the war at sea lasts a signals NCO in
the SS Division Das Reich was even more
confident my conviction is that the
destruction of Russia will take no
longer than France and then my
assumption of getting the eve in August
will still be correct I'm sure everyone
here is well acquainted the story of the
invasion which Stalin refused to believe
was coming but I would like to emphasize
a couple of points there have been
suggestions that the postponement of
Operation Barbarossa in 1941 from may to
the 22nd of June was due to Hitler's
invasion of Yugoslavia and Greece called
Operation Morita some regard this as a
critical factor in the firm Ark's
failure to reach Moscow six months later
yet almost all historians now attribute
the postponement to other factors such
as the delay in distributing Metro
Transport principally vehicles captured
from the French Army in 1940 all
problems of fuel distribution or the
difficulty of establishing forward air
fields for the Luftwaffe due to the very
heavy way rains in that in the end of
the spring but one consequence of which
there is little doubt was that the way
that Operation Morita helped convinced
Stalin that the Germans thrust south
meant that they were focusing on the
capture of the Suez Canal from the
radiation not on an invasion of the
Soviet Union the question of French
military transport it's also important
since the supposedly mechanized German
army relied on no less than 600,000
horses the French Army's surrender in
1940 completely upset Stalin's plans for
he had expected it to grind down the fur
Mart and then it emerged that almost 80%
of the neutral transport of German
infantry division's in Operation
Barbarossa was French because the French
army had failed to destroyed this was
one reason why Stalin was so fiercely
prejudiced against the French
until in December 1944 he perceived
during General de Gaulle's visit to
Moscow that he might prove
useful wildcard for him within the
Western alliance the other point I'd
like to make here quickly is that
conspiracy theories mostly neo-nazi ones
that claim that Stalin was preparing his
own preemptive strike against Germany
are frankly rubbish they are usually
based on a contingency planning document
of the 11th of May drawn up by a general
Zhukov than the chief of the General
Staff and other senior officers who were
aware of Nazi plans to invade and they
believed that the only way to stop it in
some ways was with the spoiling attack
in any case the Red Army it was in no
position to carry it out and also Stalin
was terrified of provoking Hitler on the
22nd of June 1941 news of the Nazi
invasion prompted disbelief immediately
followed by outrage right across the
Soviet Union a fierce sense of relief
also affected Soviet citizens that this
treacherous attack had released them
from the unnatural molotov-ribbentrop
alliance with Nazi Germany the young
physicist Andrei Sakharov who was later
was later greeted by an ant in a bomb
shelter in during a Luftwaffe raid on
Moscow for the first time in years she
said I feel like a Russian again Stalin
sensing this surge of patriotism did not
appeal to save its citizens to fight to
save communism he would be saved by the
very national i nationalism that he
pretended to despise just on 300,000
citizens of Leningrad joined the armed
forces in another 128,000 the militia
these battalions of alarmed cannon
fodder were expected to slow German
Panzer divisions with little more than
their bodies they had no uniforms no
transport no medical services any half
of them had rifles Soviet losses were
appalling in the Leningrad strategic
defensive operations from the 10th of
July to the 30th of September 1940
the Red Army and militia has suffered
214,000 irrecoverable losses out of
517,000 men this represented a fatal
casualty rate of 42 percent this war of
annihilation as Hitler called it was
pickiness the Russian is a tough
opponent read a German soldier we take
hardly any personals and shoot them all
instead when marching forward some took
potshots for fun at crowds of Red Army
and prisoners being herded back to
makeshift camps where they were left to
starve or freeze thousands of Soviet
citizens died in the bombing of the
cities of Belarus particularly Smolensk
and Minsk survivors fared little better
in their attempts to escape eastwards as
Arthur Army Group centre advanced along
Napoleon's route to Moscow after Minsk
began to burn a journalist noted blind
men from the home for invalids walked
along the highway in the long file tight
to one another with towels Army Group
South commanded by general field marshal
von Rundstedt advanced into Ukraine also
capturing hundreds of thousands of
prisoners in great encirclement battles
Generalfeldmarschall ritter von Leeb
Army Group north meanwhile advanced out
of East Prussia through the Soviet
occupied Baltic States
apart from a sudden counter-attack near
Lake Ilmen
German progress was slowed only by the
terrain of marsh and thick birch woods
almost half a million Leningrad
civilians were sent to dig a nearly a
thousand kilometers of earthworks and
645 kilometers of anti-tank ditches none
of these precautions saved the city from
its first great disaster on the 8th of
September 1941 the day that the Germans
took the fortress town of shlisselburg
on the southern shore of Lake Ladoga
thus cutting off Leningrad Luftwaffe
bombers targeted the food ghettos in the
south of the city columns a thick smoke
arising high
Vasiliy truck in written history
horrified at the implications it's about
a F steep route deeper his burning fire
is devouring six months food supplies
for the whole population of Leningrad
the failure to disperse the stores had
been a major error rations had to be
drafted dramatically reduced right from
the start
in addition little had been done to
bring in forward for the winter but the
greatest mistake was the failure to
evacuate more civilians fewer than half
a million leningraders have been sent
East before
the mosque a railway line had been cut
by the German advance when the siege or
blockade began the civilian population
of Leningrad stood at more than two and
a half million people including four
hundred thousand children Hitler decided
that he did not want his troops to
occupy the city instead the vow marked
word bombarded and seal it off to that
the population starve and die of disease
in fact more than 800,000 civilians died
once reduced the city itself would be
demolished and the area handed over to
Finland he wanted to eradicate the
cradle of Bolshevism Stalin refusing to
believe that the Germans could have
broken through so easily suspected
sabotage he ordered general Zhukov to
take over trusting in his ruthlessness
Zhukov flew from Moscow as soon as he
received the order on arrival he drove
straight to the military council in the
small D Institute where he claimed to
have encountered
defeatism and drunkenness he soon went
on went even further than Stalin in his
readiness to threaten the families of
soldiers who surrendered he ordered
commanders of the Leningrad front I quit
make it clear to all troops that all the
families of those who surrendered to the
enemy will be shot and they themselves
will be shot upon return from prison
clearly Zhukov did not realize that his
order if carried out to the letter would
have meant the execution of Stalin
himself because the Soviet dictators own
son
leftenant Yakov rubbish Willy had been
captured in answer
and Stalin was not entirely worried by
shoo coughs decree he just admired his
listeners and when Moscow was threatened
in November Stalin was severely tempted
to strip leningrad of troops to save the
capital he had the full sympathy for
what he saw as a city of the
intelligentsia who despised Muscovites
and were suspiciously fond of Western
Europe the battle for Moscow in November
and December 1941 and above all Hitler's
declaration of war on the United States
on the 11th of December is I think now
generally recognized as the geopolitical
turning point of the Second World War
fact the only moment when Hitler could
have won the war outright was actually
at the end of May 1940 when British
troops retreated to Dunkirk and
Churchill was under pressure from Lord
Halifax to inquire about peace terms
that might be described as the as the
very first turning point in the Second
World War but from December 1941 with
Hitler halted before Moscow and the
United States a belligerent Nazi Germany
simply could not win the psychological
turning point however did not come until
nearly a year later when the
encirclement of the German 6th army at
Stalingrad demonstrated to the world
that the Third Reich was entirely doomed
and it was in the autumn of 1942 that
both the Vermont and the Imperial
Japanese Army and Navy reached their
cumulative point that is to say they had
lost both momentum and the initiative
through overreach but allied victory was
not yet even close and the majority of
the deaths in the Second World War still
lay ahead Stalin and Hitler were both
prepared to waste the lives that are in
men and ensure their total compliance
through terrifying disciplinary measures
which they copied off each other
Stalin took the idea of punishment
battalions from the Germans and even
kept the German word RAF as in straw for
tea punishment companies
Hitler impressed by the way the Red Army
held on when he had expected it to
collapse nature decided to copy Soviet
techniques including the commissar or
political officer in the Val mark this
later became the National Socialist
leadership officer Hitler also borrow
the Saviour idea of blocking units to
prevent retreat in his case using SS and
Feld from da Murray at Stalingrad the
blocking units and the execution squads
did play a crucial role albeit on a
totally excessive scale the figure of
13,500 Soviet soldiers executed during
the Stalingrad campaign by their own
side is perhaps one of the most horrific
statistics in modern warfare but would
any Western army have managed to hold on
to Stalingrad in September and October
1942 against what was thrown at it I
think not Western armies retained a
notion that suffering had a limit at
which point you could surrender the Red
Army far more under Stalin's thumb than
the ver mark was under Hitler's had knew
such qualification one can never expect
the army of a liberal democracy to fight
as ruthlessly as that of a dictatorship
soldiers on the Eastern Front were
afraid base of their enemy and of
execution by their inside this put them
under a terrible psychological pressure
they and save it civilians were crushed
pitilessly between the two regimes Red
Army snipers at Stalingrad for example
were ordered to shoot starving Russian
children who had been tempted with
crusts of bread by a German infantryman
to fill their water bottles in the Volga
even surrender was not necessarily an
escape for German soldiers on the
Eastern Front
there was no Geneva Convention nonsense
of sticking to name rank or number I'll
never forget one protocol of
interrogation by the chief of
intelligence of the 62nd army at
Stalingrad working through an
interpreter at the bottom of the page
it was a scribbled note to say that the
interrogation had been terminated
because the subject had died of wounds
it is however images from the fighting
in Stalingrad itself that will endure
perhaps most in the memory this
represented a new form of warfare
concentrated in the ruins of civilian
life the detritus of war burnt-out tanks
showcases signal war and grenade boxes
was mixed with the wreckage of family
homes and bedsteads lamps and household
utensils while this battle in the urban
landscape was going on general Zhukov
and Vasilevsky were planning the great
country attack operation Uranus to
encircle and destroy general palaces six
army but even shook off who had sent
virtually unarmed militia battalions to
their certain death against German
Panzer divisions in 1941 had no idea of
the most cynical sacrifice of all in
November 1942 which was carried out in
his name while operation Uranus the
great plan to encircle the six army was
being prepared another offensive a huge
diversion took shape much further north
on the Kalinin and western fronts
against the german ninth army this was
called Operation Mars the main objective
of Mars was to ensure that not a single
German division could be moved from the
central part of the front to the
southern part the six Soviet armies sent
into battle as a diversion had virtually
no artillery support while the
Stalingrad operation received plenty and
this imbalance alone suggested a
staggering disregard for human life on
the part of Stalin the cording to
general pavel sudoplatov of the NKVD the
ruthlessness went far further he
described how details of operation Mars
were deliberately passed in advance to
the Germans the NKVD and GRU military
intelligence had prepared something
called Operation monastery
an infiltration of the German up there
which is their German military
intelligence
Alexander Damian off the grandson of the
leader of the kuban cossacks had been
instructed by the NKVD to allow himself
to be recruited by german military
intelligence since his family was well
known in white heavy grey circles the
Germans had already identified him
during the nazi-soviet pact as a
possible agent for them in early
November preparations were well advanced
for operation Uranus around Stalingrad
and for the diversionary attack of
Operation Mars near reserve Alexander
demyanov was now instructed by his NKVD
controllers to give the Germans the
details of operation Mars the
disinformation planted through Alexander
wrote a general sudra plot of the NKVD
chief of administration for special
tasks was kept secret even from marshal
Zhukov and was handed to me personally
by general federal fedorovitch Kuznetsov
of GRU in a sealed envelope shook off
not knowing that this disinformation
game was being played at his expense
paid a heavy price in the loss of
thousands of men under his command this
was an understatement this diversion
cost the Red Army two hundred and
fifteen thousand six hundred and
seventy-four casualties
just about the same as the total allied
casualties for d-day in the whole of the
Battle of Normandy it was one of the
most heartless sacrifices known in the
history of war all this time Stalin of
course was harping on about social
casualty as heavy casualties to
Churchill and to President Roosevelt
demanding a second front and
cross-channel invasion of northern
France but neither Britain nor the US
were in any position to launch an attack
without massive losses Churchill then
backed the development of what became
the strategic bombing campaign or
bombing offensive in an attempt to
persuade Stalin that this was a second
front and in fact in a way it was
on the 30th of May 1942 our chief
Marshall Harris of the RAF launched his
first thousand bomber raid on Cologne
this was basically a grand gesture aimed
to impress the Americans and Stalin yet
coming at a time when Churchill was
under heavy pressure this was Britain's
only substitute for the second front
British Bomber Command casualties 55,000
673 killed out of a total of 125,000
aircrew interestingly another 44 percent
death rate were also a part payment of
the blood debt owed to the Red Army
which was suffering the vast bulk of the
casualties but although Harris's
obsessive idea of forcing Germany to
surrender through bombing alone proved
totally misplaced Churchill rightly saw
that the strategic bombing campaign
would play a major part in the eventual
Soviet victory on the Eastern Front
Hitler's rage over the attacks on German
cities soon forced Hermann Goering to
withdraw more and more fighter squadrons
and 88-millimeter and hit aircraft guns
from the Eastern Front
to defend the Reich by 1944 there were
just 1,200 heavy anti-aircraft guns left
for the whole of the Eastern Front yet
more than 7,000 were back in Germany and
of course if these 88 millimeter
anti-aircraft guns which were also the
most devastating anti-tank weapon of the
whole war had not been withdrawn from
the Eastern Front one Canadian
speculated how many more Soviet soldiers
would have died the withdrawal of
Luftwaffe fighter formations leaving
only a 27 percent of Germany's total
fighter force on the Eastern Front by
April 1943 led to red army aviation
achieving air superiority for the very
first time during the latter stages of
the huge battle of kursk Savior our
superiority also meant that German
reconnaissance aircraft
could no longer roam at will over Soviet
lines and when in 1944 the Red Army
adopted its great muskie Hrothgar or
deception operations the Germans were
taken Atlee by surprise for example in
Operation Bagration
which destroyed the Germans Army Group
centre and liberated the whole of
Belarus and took them all the way up to
the gates of Warsaw one of the subjects
on which most Russian historians are
reluctant to dwell is allied support to
the Soviet Union they do not want to
acknowledge that large areas of the
Soviet Union was saved from starvation
even famine in the winter of 1942 by
American wheat and American tin supplies
some 4.5 billion tons altogether
soldiers in the Red Army knew its
provenance because we're not opening a
tin of spam in their rations they used
to joke let's open the second front
but Soviet civilians had no idea of us
support because the Soviet authorities
over stamped the markings on the sacks
of American grain to make it look as if
it was produced in the USSR most Russian
historians will not mention the total of
seventeen point five billion tons of
goods shipped by the United States to
keep the Soviet Union fighting American
steel went to Chelyabinsk in the Urals
known as tanker grad where it was turned
into the most practical tank and
mass-produced armored vehicle of the
whole of the Second World War the t-34
one could also argue that the four
hundred and thirty thousand trucks and
jeeps provided to the Red Army
transformed its mobility to such an
extent in 1943 and 1944 that without
them the Red Army would never have
reached Berlin before the Americans in
1944
say via propagandist such as Ilya
Ehrenburg made disdainful remarks in
their press claiming that the Western
Allies in Normandy were fighting the
dross of the German army but this was
true only of a few infantry divisions
the British during Operation Epsom in
Normandy found themselves up against 7
Panzer divisions including two SS Panzer
Corps the greatest concentration of
often SS since the Battle of Kursk
although statistics are hard to compare
between the Western and the eastern
France the average cavalry casualty
rates per division per month appear to
being higher in Normandy quite a lot
higher in Normandy than in the East
German losses on the Eastern Front
averaged just under a thousand per
division per month in Normandy the
average figure was around 2,300 per
division per month German soldiers who
had experienced both fronts were shaken
by the fighting in Northwest France
nevertheless the conditions under which
men fought on the Eastern Front were so
desperate that today we can hardly
imagine how they survived even many who
were there look back in amazement one
red army officer Vladimir Ivanovich
Julian F said recently nowadays I can't
believe that we were able to live in the
trenches in the open field in the snow
in the cold never taking off our shoes
or clothes with no water or source of
heat how on earth did we survive all
that between 1941 and 1945 some Red Army
soldiers those who survived the battles
along the way Fortin marched for more
than 7,500 miles in January 1945 Stalin
pretended he had saved the Americans in
the Ardenne by launching his great
winter offensive earlier this needless
to say was totally untrue the German
offensive had been halted by Christmas
Day 1944 and the Allied contra
began on the 3rd of January 1945 Stalin
did not launch his great offensive along
the Vistula and into East Prussia until
10 days later in fact Stalin should have
thanked the US Army because the back of
the German Panzer on had been smashed in
the are dere so when the Red Army's
winter offensive began in mid-january in
1945 the German army was a shadow of its
former self was incapable of resisting
the headlong charge of four Soviet
guards tank armies all the way from the
river Vista to the oder nicer line in
less than two weeks
in fact Stalin did have a very practical
reason of why he had advanced his
offensive in that January it was because
forecast meteorological forecasts
predicted a big thaw towards the end of
January and that would have meant that
his tanks would not have been able to
advance at the same rate
sailed from that point of view of this
one was purely a decision based on his
own needs
the Red Army's ultimate objective was
Berlin what Soviet propaganda called the
lair of the fascist beast the Battle for
Berlin in April and the beginning of May
1945 was the long predicted climax of
the war on the Eastern Front
but once again thousands died for vain
symbols on both sides
- Red Army divisions were thrown against
that massive and well defended building
the Reichstag to raise the red banner of
victory Stalin had actually picked the
Reichstag even though it hadn't been
used ever since 1933 with the rice tag
far but he wanted to have a particular
symbol which he could produce
competition amongst his own troops
because they were told that the first
person to get a flag up there would
receive the top Soviet award the the
hero of the Soviet Union the ghost
but on the German side Hitler a devotee
of the cinema visualized his gutter day
Moroni in Berlin amid blazing monuments
crashing down war between the two
totalitarian states of Nazi Germany and
the Soviet Union it's not just a war of
ideologies it was also a war between two
monstrous vanities the drama continued
albeit in a different way after the
Reich's Chancellery was captured by the
Red Army on the 2nd of May 1945 and a
SMERSH detachment under general Vardis
took over the Fuehrer bunker Stalin
urgently wanted to know what had become
of Hitler
SMERSH Soviet country intelligence had
turned heard from surrendering German
generals and officials but the Nazi
leader had committed suicide but nobody
could find the body eventually it was
discovered by smash operatives on the
5th of May buried in a shell hole along
with the body of Ava brown and his
adored Alsatian German Shepherd dog
blondi but Stalin didn't want anybody to
know not only did he use this as an
opportunity for accusing the Americans
of having hidden Hitler in Bavaria he
also wanted to put pressure on his own
army commanders he rang marshal Zhukov
on two occasions to taunt him with the
supposed failure to find Hitler when he
knew all the time that smash had carried
out its own autopsy on the body and had
identified it this may beggar belief but
marshal Zhukov the commander in chief in
Berlin did not discover for twenty years
not until 1965 that Hitler's body had in
fact been found this was all part of the
Byzantine world of Stalinist politics
stalin feared the popularity of shukoff
and later had him accused of bonaparte
ism my colleague of the last
twenty-three years dr. Luba Vinogradova
remarked to me once in a
go archive I think we deserved Stalin I
felt bound to disagree if any because
one can never say that a whole people
deserved an appalling leader it is in
any case one of the terrible
chicken-and-egg questions of history
whether a leader like Stalin or Hitler
are the product of their country's
history or the shaper or both on many
occasions I've been asked you know who
was the greater criminal Hitler or
Stalin and it's an interesting
philosophical question Stalin was almost
certainly responsible for more deaths
especially those of his own countrymen
and women but can one say which crime is
worse racial genocide or political
genocide the question of the definition
of genocide is raised in an apple bombs
important new book read famine about
Stalin's determination to crush the
peasantry and nationalism in Ukraine
Andrei Sakharov the great scientist and
savior dissident once observed there
although Stalin killed more people
Hitler had to be defeated first and he
was undoubtedly right a Nazi victory
over the Soviet Union in 1941 would have
been so terrible that there is no other
answer
in fact the mass starvation and enslave
and enslavement which the Nazis plan for
the population of the occupied
territories up until up to the archangel
Astrakhan line could have dwarfed even
the horrors of a holocaust The Hunger
plan set out by Helmut Bakker and
approved by Hitler envisaged the death
by starvation of 30 million Soviet
citizens after years of Soviet
propaganda it is very hard for Russians
to face the implications of their
country's past horrors he means
questioning just over 70 years and
mainly futile sacrifice and countless
millions of wrecked lives and broken
families parents sent to the gulag and
their children forced into cruel state
orphanages
for Russians therefore it is more
difficult in a way to re-examine their
history than for Germans faced with a
12-year aberration and the Soviet
victory in 1945 which even
anti-stalinist
celebrate makes it makes it even harder
to question before my book Berlin the
downfall was published in 2002 the
Russian ambassador in London explained
to me privately why his country found it
hard to question the past you must
understand the victory is sacred he was
right but it was the only the terrifying
loss of life which made it sacred
and this is why Russians have such
trouble with the subject and not just
Stalinist dinosaurs once Grigory crazy
in the Ambassador had read the book he
then publicly condemned me for lies
slander and blasphemy against the Red
Army an interesting crime in its
formulation now I'm technically liable
to up to five years imprisonment if I
get back to Russia because the book
contained rather powerful evidence from
Russian archives about the mass rapes
perpetrated by members of the Red Army
now this is because Sergei shoigu the
Minister of Defense introduced a new law
to the Duma demanding this penalty for
anyone who insults the reputation of the
Red Army in the Second World War
yeah sure i gu had said that the offence
was equivalent to holocaust denial a
very curious idea we see more and more
evidence that under Putin admiration for
Stalin is cultivated in schools and the
Kremlin controlled media a survey in
June nominated Stalin as the most
outstanding person of all time even well
ahead of Lenin and now the Russian state
itself is imitating Scotland s
xenophobia and a Stalinist reversal of
truth the greater the lie the greater
the effect this is particularly the case
in its dealings with a penance by
perverting the system of justice for
example one of the brave campaigners of
Memorial Yuri
meet chef who has been revealing the
extent of Stalinist crimes during the
Great Terror is now in prison falsely
accused of child pornography more than
30,000 people have signed the petition
to restore legality and justice in his
case Demetrius real crime was three
decades studying the mass killings of
the NKVD at Sun Dome or near the Finnish
border and the Salah vet ski islands
where the gulag
began memorial itself is accused of
being in league with foreign agents
state television accused memorial of
helping those whose aim is to destroy
the Russian state the search for
historical truth is therefore defined as
the kin to treason things have got
natively worse since the Russian
annexation of the Crimea and its
military involvement in Ukraine but to
return to my first comment on the Levada
poll which stated that 63% of Russians
believe that the Soviet Union could have
won the war without allies this ignores
the fact that the former Soviet leader
Nikita Khrushchev who certainly knew the
truth along with Stalin did acknowledge
the debt I would like to express my
candid opinion he wrote in his memoirs
about Stalin's view on whether the Red
Army and the Soviet Union could have
coped with Nazi Germany and survived the
war without aid from the United States
and Britain first I would like to tell
about some remarks Stalin made and
repeated several times when we were
discussing freely and quotes among
ourselves
he said he bluntly that if the United
States had not helped us we would not
have won the war if we had had to fight
Nazi Germany one-on-one we could not
have stood up against Germany's pressure
and we would have lost the war marshal
Zhukov said basically the same thing
when writing in 1963 a version of his
memoirs which of course was not
published at the time and couldn't be
published until after the fall of the
Soviet Union
today some say the Allies didn't really
help us but listen
when cannot deny that the Americans
shipped over to us material without
which we could not have equipped our
armies held in reserve or been able to
continue the war so 63 percent of
Russians today have fallen free totally
false idea strongly encouraged by
Putin's Kremlin and repeated again
during this year's Moscow victory
celebrations on the 9th of May thank you
very much
[Applause]
he has agreed to sign copies of his book
Stalingrad following this lecture we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and the microphone will
be brought to you
do I see a question over here no yes no
one over here please oh okay all right
let's start that first Thanks hey there
how could the Germans have succeeded in
operation typhoon and would that have
led to the downfall of the Soviet Union
if not that how would the Germans have
won the war after would have happened
and fall 1941 thank you
well there being a number of
counterfactual novels and in Robert
Harris's wonderful fatherland and all
the rest of it but as with many
counterfactual novels you can't really
take them too seriously if you're going
to look at it in a sort of literal way
of what actually did happen typhoon was
unlikely to work for the simple reason
that even if they captured Moscow and of
course Moscow was a center for
communications as well as the arms
industry it would not necessarily have
meant the end what is very striking is
that in october stalin summoned the
slaloms in such a funk at this
particular time that he has summoned the
bulgarian ambassador bulgaria was
actually an ally of Germany and the
Bulgarian ambassadors coming off I think
was probably more sympathetic to the
fellow slaves of the of Russia and he
actually gave advice to Stalin he simply
said you know you're crazy you know even
if you even if you have to retreat all
the way to the Urals you'll still win in
the end
because what he recognized and what
Stalin had failed to recognize and what
Hitler refused to recognize was that if
you take the sino-japanese war and the
Japanese invasion of China in 1937 Japan
which had a far more sophisticated army
far better equipped a far better trained
thought that even though it was in a
minority it could easily defeat the
incompetent and badly equipped and badly
led chinese nationalist armies in fact
was simply defeated by the sheer size of
the country and if you have a major
landmass into which you can withdraw
then the chance of victory even for the
sophisticated the well-equipped army
like the vel Mart is reduced very
dramatically indeed in fact there were
officers of the upper of the German
intelligence who argued very strongly
that the only chance they had of winning
in Russia against the Red Army was by
arming a million Ukrainians and using
them as an army and creating basically a
civil war in Russia but Hitler with his
obsessive racial views would not want
any Slav to be dressed in fair marked
uniform and refused the idea ironically
Himmler did not worry quite so much he
had Ukrainians dressed up and he called
them cossack troops because hitler
didn't think that cossacks were Slavs
for some reason and he also had his
Galician divisions which he called
Galician of SS who in fact of course
were Ukrainians too so it was really
only Hitler's sort of obsession that
which stopped them from using far more
local troops and that actually was their
only hope of winning at the time of
Operation typhoon the advance on Moscow
at that particular time
I I just wanted your opinion on what
would have happened if Roosevelt and
Churchill refused to let the Soviet
Russia keep control of Eastern Europe if
they had not been able to come to an
agreement about that what do you think
would have happened well I don't know if
you know the story about operation
unthinkable operation unthinkable was
when just after the end of the war in
this is already into mein 1945 Churchill
was so appalled at the way that Stalin
was ignoring any of the agreements of
elections in Poland and was deliberately
in fact they had given safe contact
passes to polish political leaders and
then probably arrested them and then
murdered quite a few of them in prison
and Churchill was so angry about this
that he summoned the British Chiefs of
Staff and said will you please study the
possibility of doing an about-turn and
pushing the Russians putting pushing the
Red Army back we'll try and get the
Americans to come in on our side and all
the rest of it now when can mum might
have understood his emotions and
frustration but actually this was
madness what unfortunately happened was
that a message and was sent to Field
Marshal Montgomery in Germany saying
collect up all the fairmark weapons we
might be rearming the Germans to push
back the Russians unfortunately
unfortunately a British spy can cross
pick this up
in some of the classified material and
warn the Russian so you could imagine
the Soviets this confirmed every single
one of their worst suspicions which we
actually were untrue that the British
and the Americans want to do a secret
deal with the Nazis against the Soviet
Union but this was one of the disastrous
consequences of that not surprisingly
the Americans quite rightly realized
that any way they wanted to finish the
war in Japan
they want to get their troops out and
all the rest of it and this actually
horrified Churchill but he hoped that
Truman who was sharing a rather more
realistic view towards Stalin and say
Bruce Abell had that he would change his
view but unfortunately Truman certainly
was persuaded by Davis the former US
ambassador to the Soviet Union during
the trying time of the show trials was
sort of loved Stalin and thought he was
wonderful and persuaded Truman not to
listen to Churchill which is probably a
good thing because frankly Churchill's
plan was madness I mean any idea of say
telling the British army that you're nug
and fight the Russians when they thought
they were all about to go home and after
they'd been told that actually millions
of or tens of thousands of British lives
had been saved by the sacrifices of the
Red Army and they'd seen all of the
newsreel films basically extolling the
sacrifice of Red Army
you know I think they would have downed
weapons and there might even have been a
mutinous they would be integrally
disastrous if it's gonna add anyway
fortunately at the British Chiefs the
staff came back and said sorry Prime
Minister operation unthinkable is truly
unthinkable so that was that was the end
of that one but I'm afraid that's why
people go on about sort of you know was
the ultra betrayal and all the rest of
it actually the trouble about Yalta was
in many ways Yalta was the political
consequence of the military decisions
taken at the Tehran conference once you
had made the decision and agreed with
Stalin that you were going to invade
through northern Europe
and you were not going to go into
Central Europe which is what Churchill
wanted to do then afraid the outcome was
more or less inevitable in that in that
way Stalin was not going to give up give
up Poland once he had his hands on
Poland he had occupied the country there
was no way he was going to give it up
because as far as he was concerned a he
hated the pose as a result of the
humiliation he'd suffered in 1921 during
the Russia Russian Soviet polish war
and he always hated he had sort of
visceral hatred of the poles and there
was no way that he was going to allow
them to be independent in any way so I
don't think that there wasn't very much
that could have perhaps changed at the
end of the war this question goes back
to the latter part of your discussion I
recently had a very interesting
conversation with a young Russian in
Chicago who grew up in Russia Moscow and
is now a venture capitalist with a
European company and he's spent a good
time bit of time in Germany and he said
he was impressed that when he was in
Germany of how the Germans have quote
repented for their sins and quote of
identifying themselves as having been
perpetrators of terrible crimes that
they do not wish to repeat again but he
said he as a Russian he has never heard
anything like that and there just seems
to be no willingness to accept the fact
that they have erred in the past and he
thinks it's actually swinging back to a
more nationalistic fervor under under
Putin do you do you see them as well I
agree absolutely
I think that's an entirely right no I
think it is very impressive the way that
sort of you know Germany has faced the
far past in the way that it had it
wasn't always a very straightforward
process it must be said interestingly it
was in January in 1979 that the first
real emotional change happened in
Germany in terms of war guilt over the
second world war and it was when that
Hollywood miniseries Holocaust with
Meryl Streep was broadcast in Germany
and that had a huge effect that was when
all the young suddenly started
interrogating their parents saying what
did you know about it at the time and it
almost sort of caused an
intergenerational civil war in in in in
Germany but he did certainly wait things
up but I mean on the other hand let's
face
is always going to be a minority as we
saw with the recent elections of ifj and
there have been times and there was a
time in for example in 2002 when
suddenly Germans started seeing
themselves as the victims of 1945 partly
because of the mass rapes the total the
huge ethnic cleansing of Germans from
Central Europe and all the rest of it so
the world number who saw themselves as
victims there but I mean when you
compare to the Japanese who've never
really apologized or ready faced up to
their guilt and as for the Austrians who
always regard themselves as the first
victims of Nazi Germany unless my German
friends used to say very well there's no
Nazi like an Austrian Nazi say you know
you you really do you know you the
important thing is you must never
generalize and if the history teaches is
anything it's it's not not to generalize
in that particular way but yes as in
Russia your Russian friend was
absolutely right there's very little
hint certainly and I'm afraid within the
historical community apart from one or
two very courageous young Russian
historians they are they will stick to
the Kremlin line apart for anything else
near perfectly well that if they do rock
the boat they won't be allowed inside
the archives again so you know that that
sort of Korea Korea death from the
historians point in point of view there
it's in Russia you don't take unless
you're pretty brave you don't take on
your then take on the state I was
wondering if you had any thoughts on
since you've written extensively on the
Battle of Stalingrad on vastly
Grossman's novel life and fate mm-hmm
you know he presents the two systems as
kind of mirror images of each other and
this he was very thirsty did it yeah
yeah yeah and it seems to me it's one of
the more powerful historical novels to
come out of the Soviet experience but
how true do you think that novel is to
the you know in its account of
Stalingrad and what it reveals about the
nature of the Soviet system in
particular I think it's I think it's
very accurate in that particular sense I
mean with Luba we
did a book together called a writer at
war with all of Grossman's jottings from
his notebooks which weren't censored
like a lot of the articles afterwards
and there are different versions of life
and fate I mean the way that that novel
which makes people I mean it was a
deliberate it's faces it was a
deliberate act of homage to Tolstoy by
calling it life and fate it was it was
definitely the Stalinist era war and
peace and it is a major novel it's one
of the probably one of the greatest
novels certainly coming out of Russia of
the whole period as Solzhenitsyn and
everybody else acknowledged
unfortunately it's not had the effect
that the influence that it should have
done in Russia a rather bad transfer
rather bad sort of version of it came
out just before the fall of communism
and then this came slightly back to what
the other John was saying that you know
this thing we're about Russians didn't
want to look at the past not if it's
uncomfortable and that's why I'm afraid
he's sort of fallen into not disregard
rather than disrepute while in places
like France and I'll swear Grossman is
regarded with huge admiration and as
probably the most important novelist
coming out of coming out of Russia and
more important even than than sort of
many of his contemporaries certainly
Arenberg who is actually also a great
friend but you know even even even more
than some of the some of the battle name
ones hi there
considering the current Stalinist
conduction of the Russian government how
does that behavior affect the situation
between the United States and North
Korea and what are some ways the United
States can maintain and build up the
turns versus Russia today I don't often
agree with Vladimir Putin but I fear
that he was right when he said that
North Korea will be made to eat grass
rather than give up their nuclear
program and I'm afraid that it has got
to a stage where they feel or persuaded
themselves that there any hope to ward
off
an American attack is through actually
having a nuclear weapon which means that
there's no way that sort of negotiation
I think is going to achieve very much in
that way as far as Putin is concerned
I've been hearing rumors and stories
they haven't yet been confirmed at all
that quite a bit of the technology has
actually come from Russia that Putin
wanting to basically tweak the American
Tiger's tail was actually the reason why
that the there's been such an
extraordinary acceleration in the
development of the nuclear weapons in
North Korea is due to apparently to
Russian help I've been hearing so that I
think is pretty scary in its own
particular way and it's also that sort
of theories say that present relations
with China mainly over trade that I mean
that has a wider wider influence in its
in fashion means that I didn't think
we're going to see very much in the way
of China helping to keep North Korea
under control so very very hard to say
and I think that Russia has not got over
the humiliation of that period
immediately after the collapse of the
Soviet Union it was something I remember
and even when we were in the Ministry of
Defence archives of sort of Oba booshka
saying isn't it wonderful that race had
Gorbachev is dying of cancer
I hope she's dying in pain because he
betrayed the Soviet Union and all the
rest of it so you can imagine this is
sort of the mentality of the way that
the West won the Cold War by a trick and
I didn't think that we any of us sort of
really handle things in a very full
sighted way by encouraging some of the
or allowing the sort of the sudden jerk
into capitalism in the sense that it was
a form of gangsta capitalism which took
over rather than any form of sort of
Western development of a free enterprise
so there was a huge bitterness and I
remember at the time of the way that
when you had sort of war widows and
veterans from the Second World War
begging in the Metro and all the rest of
it this produced real anger and
bitterness and so I don't think that we
can expect very much in the way of real
friendship coming out of Russia and
anything I think that Putin can do to
inconvenience or embarrass the West were
probably going to see more off so I'm
afraid I'm not terribly optimistic in
that particular in that particular way
thank you very much for your time
tonight in one of his letters Winston
Churchill noted that in a typical
Churchillian phrase that the English
lion was trapped in between the Russian
bear and American Buffalo but was the
only one that knew the way and the
context being Americans specifically
Roosevelt's dealings with and views of
Stalin versus his own Churchill's in
what ways did Roosevelt and Churchill
differ in their views and handling of
Stalin and the Red Army I think that
Roosevelt who had great charm but was
also pretty cynical in many ways and
quite often used his charm in a fairly
cynical way thought that he had charmed
Stalin and he thought he could make
Stalin into a friend well I think as any
Savior diplomat of the era or anybody
who knew the Soviet Union well knew
perfectly well that Stalin did not make
friends certainly not with foreigners
and who he detested this cruelly and not
even with not even with I'm sure we say
his in his in people so from that point
of view I think that Roosevelt was
actually in some ways curiously rather
naive in believing that he could sort of
bend Stalin to his own will Churchill
who I think that you know I've always
suspected slightly there might have been
an element of bipolar in Churchill
because he was the black dog he was up
and down in many
oceans I mean there was the famous case
of that when he had to go I think it was
I'm Fred sorry I can't remember top my
head is October 42 whenever it was when
he had to go and explain that was going
to be no cross-channel invasion and
there wasn't even likely to be the new
follower year and Stalin was absolutely
in a fury and bitter to Churchill and
all the rest of it and Churchill was so
appalled that he told Sir Archibald
Clark Carr the British ambassador that
he was going to fly back the next day
and all the rest of it and Clark car
thank God calmed him down enough and was
radiant and then the next day Stalin was
sweetness and light and invited
Churchill into his private apartment in
the Kremlin and brought in his daughter
Svetlana and all the rest of it and they
had a sort of family dinner together and
Churchill was completely bowled over say
it wasn't as if although he knew deep
down what Stalin's character was like he
was still susceptible to flattery and
should we say superficial friendship in
that particular way but when it came to
Yalta I think that was where already the
real split was coming I mean Roosevelt
was only interested in the United
Nations that was to be his legacy and
all the rest of it and that was why he
was prepared to basically Excel the
polls which horrified Churchill at the
time and also the fact that he was sort
of making jokes with Stalin against
Churchill trying to prove to Saul in
that you know he was independent of the
British and so forth but the the the
British were certainly horrified at the
idea that there was absolutely no common
front between the Western Allies and
Stalin in that particular crucial moment
so you know very very hard to tell
anyway church will always loved using
animal metaphors my favorite one course
is Churchill on the go when he used to
describe the girl who's looking like a
female llama surprised in her bath a
member and when one thinks of subtlety
goes very a courtier attitude which did
look slightly like a sort of camel or a
llama
it was the perfect description anyway
thank you all very much indeed
[Applause]
[Music]